with her gentle gaze and athletic
posture this cow is a beauty she bears
the number 1 9 to 9 but everyone knows
her as Emily her coat gleams and she's
an outstanding producer all reasons why
she was recently ranked among the best
cows in the state of
mecklenburg-vorpommern four years old
she has already had carved twice and
produces 50 litres of milk a day
she's one of 800 high performance cows
on this dairy farm Dean and kippers the
Dutchman is the herd manager Emily is
one of his best animals
she had a calf in December and last week
I inseminated her and I hope she's
pregnant again so a new ones on its way
off my hope so otherwise it can't
continue why not some points just not
giving milk she has calf again to keep
producing milk what happens to my cow
that stops giving milk after the
slaughterhouse the carp dairy farm
doesn't slaughter cows that's done
elsewhere female calves begin producing
milk at two years of age male calves are
sold off to sausage makers all of that
makes money but not as much as this a
biogas plant turns cattle dung into
electric energy for the public power
grid without me Thane the farmer
couldn't pay his bills because the price
of milk has tanked he's not getting
enough per litre your boy
we need 35 cents to cover our costs and
just break even no profit there at all
at the moment milk whole sales for 19 to
20 cents so we lose fifteen cents per
litre do the math 20,000 liters means a
loss of around 3,000 euros a day
without biogas dairy farm owner Kristian
carp would have given up long ago the
subsidies the EU will be paying dairy
farmers are little comfort carp has
around 20 employees on his humane farm
the stolen milking machines are as
modern as can be
this facility is considered the Mercedes
among milking stands in recent years
Kristian carp has invested 2.4 million
euros in equipment wasn't that a bit of
a risk
ups and downs used to average out over
the years but last year they repealed
the system that regulated how much each
farmer could produce there have always
been times where milk prices were down
but prices have been low for a long time
now I'll have to recoup what I'm losing
now in the next years that'll be very
difficult and who will bear the burden
the cows are driven to the milking stand
three times a day
Emily finds her spot by herself the
Machine recognises her immediately cow
number one nine to nine projected
production this time is 16 litres will
she fulfill expectations
this is what she was bred for to produce
twice as much milk as cows did 20 years
ago now though if dairy farmers in
Germany are to survive overproduction
has to be drastically reduced Germany
needs three to five percent less
production we already have wool
warehouses full of powdered milk betting
backed by 10% would send a signal and
raise the price fast that's the law of
supply and demand why isn't that done
Farms would have to pull together
currently each farmer secures his own
liquidity by producing as much milk as
possible it's absurd but we have to
produce large volumes to cover our costs
and pay our bills
that means emily has to produce lots too
right now she's reached 12 litres now 13
it's like a race she's meant to finish
in 10 minutes and the finish line's in
sight emily is one of the last cows here
to shut the milking pump and she's
reached her 16 litre quota
she seems a little dazed but her working
day still isn't over this evening in a
few hours she'll be milked again